this is one of those times where this
feels like work
the other woman stars Cameron Diaz
Leslie Mann Kate Upton and Nicki Minaj
this movie is about three women who all
find out that they have been dating and
one of them married to the exact same
man and they decide to unite their
forces to have revenge against this man
and make his life a living hell because
he is just a dick now you might be
thinking Chris why are you reviewing
this movie I mean it's like a chick
flick where three women unite against
men I mean it's just gonna be a female
empowerment movie why would you even
want to go see this movie I'll tell you
why I want to go see this movie because
this is what I do and I try hard to see
everything there's a chance this movie
could be really funny and I was hoping
that it would be unfortunately it's not
funny at all
and I'm going to explain to you some
very serious things that I have wrong
with this movie now I'm talking to women
out there my female viewers you guys are
awesome thank you so much for watching
but I want you to really think about
something as I continue on this review
the other woman is a film that is billed
as a female empowerment movie it's like
girls come to see this movie we're gonna
kick some guys balls a lot and we want
you to enjoy this it's gonna make women
look great it's gonna make you guys look
strong and independent because you don't
need those stupid men right this movie
is actually in my opinion misogynistic I
never say stuff like that ever I am NOT
the kind of guy who goes to movie and
goes that movie was misogynistic oh my
goodness gracious oh that movie had
violence in it oh my word that is some
controversial stuff I'm going to write
to the filmmakers and say that you guys
are dumb I never do that kind of stuff I
like movies I like being entertained
this movie bothered me though because it
doesn't understand what it's trying to
be it's movies it's trying to empower
females but all the women ever do
throughout the entire movie is talk
about men there's something out there
called the Bechdel test it was invented
by a cartoonist in the 80s it's a test
that asks viewers if you can locate a
film that has at least two female
characters in it that talk about
anything besides men it's actually very
hard to do I haven't even talked about
the
fact that it isn't even funny it's just
not very funny it has a whole bunch of
stupid slapstick humor or the people
falling out of windows and running
through glass there's a course as seen
in which the guy is given a laxative and
he has to poop a lot in the bathroom
that completely rips off Dumb and Dumber
and every other scene in which a guy is
given a laxative like bringing down the
house with Steve Martin how many times
our filmmakers gonna go hey we don't
have anything to do so let's just have
someone to give that guy laxative and
he's gonna poop a lot this film doesn't
actually understand what its demographic
is because it's trying to be empowering
to women but you have Kate Upton in
there who literally has a two-minute
scene in which she runs in slow motion
with her boobs just close-up which don't
get me wrong
nice to look at Kate Upton is a very
attractive lady but I also have Google
image shirts if I really want to get
deep and down and dirty with that I have
to go see this movie to see that but my
point is it's trying to be empowering to
women but it's also like hey here's Kate
Upton gawk at her that's what we want
you to do and it was about the halfway
point through this movie that I realized
this movie actually isn't any of the
things that's trying to be it's just an
assemblage of various parts that a
studio thinks will get certain people
into the seats that's all it is they're
like okay let's have women beat up on a
guy and hate on the guy so we'll get
some girls in the theater who want to
have a girls night out and enjoy that
that's fine but hey how about we get
some guys in the theater too we'll have
one of the girls be Kate Upton because
she's very hot that's all this movie is
so women out there who are looking for a
film that in some way empowers you or
makes women look good this is not that
movie this movie makes women look awful
I like women women are cool I grew up
with two sisters you know I'm used to
being around a lot of women this movie
makes you guys look bad so don't go to
see it if you want to support a film
that's trying to make you guys look good
because this is not that movie and it's
not funny either it's just not even
funny like I haven't even talked about
the basic ideas of what a film is be
entertaining be funny this movie wasn't
any of those things to me it was just a
cliched assemblage of scenes we've seen
in other places before I'm gonna give
the other woman in F not just because it
wasn't funny not just because I didn't
care about the characters but because
it's entire idea of empowering women is
a giant lie
guys and girls if you have seen this
movie let me know what you thought below
if you're a girl let me know if you
agree with me because look I'm on your
guys side I want to see a movie that's
like yeah that woman's kick-ass like
look at black widow or uma Thurman and
Kill Bill these are characters who are
like yeah I don't give a shit about
anything I'm just gonna kick some ass
and I'm awesome guys thanks so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes